so well the simple version is just to
tell you what the terms in the equation
mean which is the e means energy and
that's equal to m mass times c the speed
of light squared
energy can be measured in joules
mass of a particle could be measured in
kilograms so if you're going to relate
them you have to relate them with some
factor
and the factor that does it is this
square of this speed of light
taken at face value it means energy is
equivalent to mass so that if you were
to look at newton's laws of motion and
say that masses attract this now implies
that energy is attracted by a another
mass so if the a light wave with energy
goes near a planet or the sun it's
actually bent
by it because it's attracted so it's
saying that energy is equivalent to mass
the consequence of it is quite dramatic
because the speed of light squared is a
huge number the speed of light in meters
per second is
three times ten to the eight three
hundred million meters per second you
square that
and you've got
uh oh rubbish they're nine times ten to
the sixteen
so you've ordered ten to the seventeen
there's a conversion factor so a very
small amount of mass
is equivalent to a huge amount of energy
physical terms what it means is that
there is actually an energy associated
with mass
it's something that just sort of falls
out sort of almost automatically from
special relativity that it's just
something that that comes out of the
equations
but obviously it's an incredibly
powerful result because it basically
means that whenever you've got a mass
you have a source of energy and so you
know if you're if you uh have a fusion
bomb for example you actually convert
some of that mass directly into energy
but it basically is another way of
saying that mass is just a way of
storing energy but it's not even the
right equation
the proper equation is e squared equals
m squared c to the fourth plus another
term involving the momentum which is an
extra p squared c squared
the mass in e equals mc squared can
either be the rest mass
and that's what it's usually thought of
that's where the the object isn't moving
and and so it's it's actually just got
an intrinsic mass and so it's got an
intrinsic energy associated with it or
it could be what's known as the
relativistic mass and and if it's the
relativistic mass then it's including
the momentum and i think i'm probably
agreeing with roger
in the textbooks you'll often see the
the the
the bear masses m with a little
subscript zero beside it just to
make it clear that that's not including
the momentum of the particle the whole
equation is never explained because
people like you don't want us to write
down equations because they're boring
haha but if you do it all properly
that's what it it is and if you don't do
it properly then you can't explain why
energy is attracted to
gravitationally to objects nor can you
explain how a photon which doesn't have
any mass
behaves the way it does
i think an interesting aspect is why is
it the square of the speed of light why
isn't it
the square of the speed of sound
which is a much lower number and um
for that you have to look
at what einstein did what albert
einstein did when he was
coming up with this theory of special
relativity
without any extra work it sort of falls
out of the analysis of special
relativity that it's just a result that
comes along and it's very nice when you
just get a result that just sort of
falls out without any extra work but
actually on its own has a huge amazing
implications for the laws of physics the
people that i've spoken to and when i
give
public talks the people who attend it
certainly have an idea that you've got
energy and mass i don't think they often
realize quite how significant it is and
quite how broad that equation is in
explaining phenomena that we experience
they they just tend to think of it in
the world of particle physics or
something rather it's rather extreme but
in fact it accounts for the binding of
of atoms
right if you've got the constituents of
atoms and you just you just measure
their mass
then you put them together the mass
drops and and the mass drops because of
the binding energy and the thing that
explains that binding energy is equals
mc squared the correct equation even if
the momentum is zero is e squared equals
m squared c to the fourth and if you
take the square root of that you can get
negative energies
coming out
and iraq noticed this
and interpreted the negative energy
states as the anti-particles so you now
get something for nothing if you use the
correct equation you can take the square
root come out with a negative energy
solution and then interpret in quantum
mechanics as the anti-particle and he
predicted this
well before anybody did the experiment
and discovered the positron so the
proper equation is much richer
the public can't cope with anything more
complicated than e equals m c squared
and even that's so full of meaning